antes de adentrarnos en el tema de la
electrólisis vamos a repasar la
estructura de una celda voltaica para
que podamos compararlo con una celda
electrolítico muy bien así que una celda
voltaica verdad utiliza una reacción
redox espontánea verdad para producir
una corriente eléctrica así que si
empezamos con electrodos de zinc
entonces el zinc sólido se va a
convertir en iones de zinc dos positivos
verdad así que el zinc sólido en
realidad pierde dos electrones verdad
tenemos que el zinc es sólido pierde dos
electrones para convertirse en iones de
zinc dos positivos y como hay una
pérdida de electrones entonces tenemos
un proceso de oxidación muy bien aquí en
este caso tenemos un proceso de
oxidación y la oxidación está ocurriendo
en nuestro electrodo de zinc verdad así
que el electrodo de zinc tiene que ser
uno
a no muy bien en este caso tenemos que
es un ánodo el electrodo de zinc es
digamos nuestra fuente de electrones
verdad así que en realidad es un
electrodo negativo ahora bien estos
electrones viajan a través de este cable
digamos verdad aquí tenemos nuestros dos
electrones viajando en el cable para
producir una corriente eléctrica cuando
esos dos electrones alcanzan nuestro
electrodo de cobre en realidad tenemos
que hay guiones de cobre dos positivos
en esta solución verdad así que el cobre
2 positivo los iones de cobre 2 positivo
de la solución cuando obtienen esos dos
electrones verdad entonces eso se
convierte en cobre sólido y es
exactamente lo que tenemos aquí verdad
justamente cuando los iones de cobre dos
positivos tienen los electrones se
convierten en cobre sólido y en este
caso es la semi reacción de reducción
cierto y por supuesto entonces como hay
una reducción en el electrodo
y cobre entonces este electrodo será el
cátodo cierto aquí tenemos el cátodo así
que el electrodo de cobre debe ser
nuestro electrodo positivo ahora bien
aquí tenemos nuestra reacción espontánea
verdad entonces el potencial de es el de
estándar que hemos denotado como es 0
tiene que ser un valor positivo verdad
de hecho esto resulta ser de 1.10 volts
y recordemos que cuando tenemos un valor
positivo para el potencial de celda
significa que tenemos una reacción
espontánea y por lo tanto podemos
producir una corriente eléctrica
ahora vamos a comparar la celda voltaica
con la celda electrolítica que tenemos
de la derecha así que una celda
electrolítica verdad utiliza una
corriente eléctrica para llevar a cabo
una reacción redox no espontánea eso es
lo importante es una reacción no
espontánea muy bien así que si nos
fijamos en la reacción completa que
tenemos
aquí abajo empezamos con cobre sólido y
iones de 52 positivos en solución acuosa
y de hecho podríamos ver fácilmente que
esta es la reacción inversa de la que
teníamos anteriormente verdad así que
por ejemplo los reactivos que tenemos en
este caso coinciden con los productos
que teníamos en el caso anterior los
reactivos de este caso coinciden con los
productos del caso anterior así que para
encontrar el potencial de es el de
estándar lo único que tenemos que hacer
es tomarnos este número pero con signo
contrario verdad simplemente porque
hemos revertido la reacción así que en
este caso el potencial de es el de
estándar será igual a menos 1 punto 10
volts y por supuesto un valor negativo
para el potencial de celda significa que
tenemos una reacción redox no espontánea
que era lo que teníamos exactamente aquí
muy bien entonces aquí tenemos una
reacción no espontánea y por supuesto
esto no ocurre digamos por su propia
cuenta
el cobre sólido
no se va a convertir en iones de cobre 2
positivo y el zinc 2 positivos no se va
a convertir en zinc sólido necesita
cierta ayuda para poder hacerlo así que
esto en realidad necesita un voltaje
externo una fuente de voltaje externo
como una batería para poder llevar a
cabo esta reacción y forzarla a que
ocurra así que digamos necesitamos una
batería por aquí muy bien y por supuesto
necesitamos que la terminal negativa que
desde el lado izquierdo mientras que la
terminal positiva debe quedar del lado
derecho muy bien así que esta es nuestra
fuente de voltaje y al menos necesitamos
1.10 volts para para forzar esta
reacción a que ocurra y en la práctica
resulta ser que necesitamos un poquito
más de 1.10 bolsas y que nuestra
terminal negativa de la batería es en
donde vamos a obtener los electrones los
electrones vienen digamos desde esta
parte muy bien vienen de la terminal
negativa de la batería y digamos liberan
electrones
hacia el electrodo de zinc así que los
electrones son forzados o son enviados
hacia los electrodos de zinc verdad
vamos a dibujar aquí digamos estos dos
electrones y lo que ahora tenemos son
iones de 52 positivo en esta solución
por supuesto estos iones de zinc dos
positivos tienen la oportunidad de ser
reducidos verdad es decir si esos
guiones de zinc dos positivos ganan
estos electrones entonces se convierten
en zinc sólido verdad entonces esto
forma zinc sólido vamos a ponerlo
digamos con un color gris aquí esto
empieza a formar zinc sólido y de hecho
se forma en el electrodo de zinc verdad
así que el 5-2 positivo gana 2
electrones para formar zinc sólido y por
supuesto esto en este caso será una semi
reacción de reducción voy a escribirlo
bien esto será una semi reacción
reducción y como en este caso la
reducción está ocurriendo en el
electrodo de zinc entonces tiene que ser
un cátodo verdad este electrodo de zinc
en este caso tiene que ser un cátodo y
en este caso el electrodo de zinc es más
negativo muy bien en este caso será
negativo ahora bien la batería está
jalando electrones desde el lado del
electrodo de cobre cierto en este caso
está jalando los electrones desde el
electrodo de cobre así que en esencia el
electrodo de cobre está perdiendo
electrones verdad y los electrones están
yendo hacia la batería que tenemos aquí
los electrones están digamos yendo hacia
la terminal positiva de la batería y eso
hace que el electrodo de cobre sea
relativamente positivo así que en este
caso tendremos que este electrodo es
positivo y por supuesto en este sitio lo
que está ocurriendo es una oxidación
cierto tenemos una oxidación lo que está
ocurriendo es que el cobre sólido está
electrones y pasa a esta solución como
iones de cobre 2 positivo así que
nosotros sabemos que la pérdida de
electrones es oxidación y por lo tanto
este electrodo tiene que ser ahora el
ánodo así que en esencia el electrodo de
cobre está perdiendo masa a lo largo del
tiempo y podemos ver la diferencia entre
la celda voltaica y la celda
electrolítica verdad la celda voltaica
crea una corriente debido a que teníamos
una reacción redox espontánea verdad
pero en el caso de la celda
electrolítica teníamos una reacción
redox que no es espontánea así que para
que esto ocurra necesitamos una corre
corriente necesitamos una fuente de
voltaje externo así que podemos incluso
remarcar el hecho de que los signos
verdad los signos de los electrodos son
opuestos en el caso de la celda voltaica
y la electrolítica por ejemplo podemos
ver en este caso que el ánodo verdad era
el electrodo de zinc en este caso
era nuestro electrodo negativo y eso es
porque el electrodo de zinc era nuestra
fuente de electrones verdad aquí tenemos
nuestros electrones así que esto lo hace
nuestro electrodo negativo pero del otro
lado el electrodo negativo verdad este
electrodo negativo era el cátodo y eso
se debe a que los electrones están
siendo forzados por la batería así que
los signos de los electrodos son
opuestos para la celda voltaica y la
electrolítica ahora bien notemos que
para la celda electrolítica verdad en
este caso el electrodo negativo coincide
con la terminal negativa de la batería y
por supuesto el electrodo positivo
verdad en este caso coincide con la
terminal positiva de la batería así que
esta es una forma muy buena de recordar
que electrodos tienen que signos en las
celdas electrolíticas sólo hay que
fijarnos en las terminales de la batería